let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
good friday
[Music]
is it a good friday i guess it's a good
friday because we get to read
the seditious
sex messages
between
mike lee and mark meadows and people
just keep
mark meadows just keeps getting his his
sext messages his seditious
sext messages
um revealed here
you know mike lee and mark metals really
in this uh this sexting top saga this
seditious sexting saga
oh my god happy [ __ ] easter weekend
huh
um in this saga that is the big lie
and the and the big steel as it was the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup
mike lee and mark mendel's just boy they
it could have overturned the government
of the united states if it weren't for
that
pesky pesky pesky constitution
hell boy
boy are they are they interesting to see
how hellbent they were on
subverting the united states
constitution [ __ ] all over it
ripping it up into shreds and taking
over the constitution of the united
states tearing down our government our
democracy so that way their cheeto dust
mobster could be king
king
as it were
good morning to you all good morning
amanda good morning robin debbie from
salt lake is here kathy is from here
christina captain terp is here
patrice from facebook is here
janie mike from facebook is here jay is
here linda's here everybody is here this
morning welcome welcome welcome you know
we come to you every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch go to youtube and
search the tony michael's podcast
subscribe to our channel there
and then now we come to you live
every single weekday from the midas
touch facebook page
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific for
two hours every single weekday for all
of you new listeners out there so go
subscribe on the youtube channel so you
don't miss a thing
because if you do miss it it's okay you
can go over to the youtube channel and
re-watch
but we broadcast live two hours every
single weekday monday through friday
today's a special day for all you new
listeners out there on friday we go
through the bonehead of the week poll
bonehead of the week you can go to
twitter and follow us at tony michael's
pod where you
you the listener gets to vote for the
bonehead of the week
and then on fridays in the second hour
me and my co-host and executive producer
gabe sanchez
we go through the bonehead of the week
breakdown we break down your vote you
get to choose we break it down for you
so today in the second hour stick around
because we will have bonehead of the
week
for the week so go to the
twitter page at tonymichaelspod follow
us there
you can vote every single week we're
just practicing democracy is all we're
doing every single week when you vote
and this is uh
clearly this is a democracy with bone
end of the week it's kind of weird
though because you gotta vote for
boneheads right so you wouldn't normally
it's the only time you'd get to vote for
like marjorie taylor greene or lauren
beaubert or charlie kirk
as it were this week or rhonda saying
it's the only time you'd actually vote
for him to be
something
but they are bonehead of the week so we
practice democracy we break down your
vote every single friday in the second
hour of the tony michaels podcast so
stay tuned today in the second hour we
have the breakdown of this week's poll
bonehead of the week also i have a
special person on today term limits are
being talked about on twitter today uh
dianne feinstein you know there's been
several stories in the last few days
about her cognitive impairment possibly
um everyone seems to think that it is a
known fact
that senator
dianne feinstein from california
mind is slipping
she doesn't remember conversations
there's all sorts of things you could
say
about senator feinstein and her mind
slipping she's 88 years old
now we talked about it a little
yesterday and i talked about term limits
and why term limits are [ __ ] stupid
it's dumb it's a really stupid thing
it's a really stupid thing
it's it's it's not even it's not just
dumb policy it's really stupid to talk
about too but
everyone wants to talk about it so
that's what we're going to talk about a
little bit today we're bringing on your
favorite political strategist
rachel bittikoffer
rachel will be joining us today
at the bottom of the hour
this hour the first hour and we will be
talking about
term limits and why
are term limits good or term limits bad
is it really good for democracy is it
not good for democracy
and i got my opinion some of you heard
it yesterday and we'll keep pounding
this drum
there are certain states that have
term limits on their legislators and it
is awful god-awful it's horrible it's
terrible
and it's bad for the state it's bad for
the government it's bad for the people
it's horrible and we'll explain i'll
explain why we'll see what rachel's
opinion is i'm sure she has a really
good take on it
i wonder if we disagree you think me and
rachel are gonna disagree on the term
limits what do you think do you think
we'll disagree
on term limits where do they suck
i mean it sucks to suck but
happy happy happy easter everyone's here
steve from facebook is here jamie from
facebook mary from facebook carol
everyone is here this morning welcome
welcome welcome to the tony michaels
podcast you guys know
if you go over to the youtube channel
that's why you want to subscribe because
you can go over to the youtube channel
and get in the chat
and you can do a super chat it's a super
chat
[Music]
super chat and you can chat on facebook
as well or on twitch i can see your
comments i can't see them from twitter
twitter when they when they redid their
periscope thing
they do not push through
their comments through twitter i don't
know why i have no idea why they did
that
uh they they had periscope and
they changed it they got rid of
periscope or something i don't know what
the hell they did how the hell are we
supposed to know maybe elon must go fix
it once he buys twitter
uh mark cuban is trending because elon
musk
is running a pump and dump scheme i
think that's what mark cuban is saying
so we'll probably go through that when
we go through the tweety tweets and
trendy trends and we might as well we
might as well go ahead and get into the
tweety tweets and trinitrons and for all
you new listeners out there
that's what we do
every weekday too we go through the
tweet tweets and the trendy trends we
see what's trending we go through the
news
and we talk about it
so let's get into it before rachel gets
here let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the tony michaels
podcast we have reached a part of the
show where we go through the tweety
tweets and trendy trends the shitless
roundup
boy is there some [ __ ] to round up today
we're gonna do a lot of rounding up
from the week
when we go over the bonehead of the week
but there are a few things i want to
show you
that aren't going to be in the bone end
of the week
that are going around uh here's my tweet
about term limits this morning let's
make this a little bigger so you can see
come on there we go okay term limits are
really stupid idea don't think so katie
porter
now are you happy okay so we'll explain
that more when rachel gets on but that
should be enough evidence katie porter
should be enough evidence of why term
limits are a really stupid idea
why would you want katie porter to be
termed out that's really dumb that's
really [ __ ] stupid okay mike lee is
trending
a while back
twitter is really surprised that mike
lee is a fascist and he wants to
overturn the constitution he's like oh
constitution constitution constitution
constitution his entire career
if you want to call it a career
constitution i got a pocket constitution
that makes me a patriot i bought one off
amazon i've never read it i keep it in
my pocket and i wave it around when i
need to at liberals
people on twitter are surprised that
mike lee is a fascist
come on get the [ __ ] out of here here's
a tweet
from october 7th
2020
we're not a democracy what a [ __ ]
bonehead if you need any more evidence
that mike lee or republicans or anyone
who you're talking to
is a [ __ ] fascist if you want to
smoke them out
if you want to know
just ask them are we in democracy
they'll say now we're a republic we're
not a democracy
they're a [ __ ] fascist
that's that's one way to tell like right
there boom right off the bat we're not a
democracy they're they clearly have not
looked up the definition of [ __ ]
words
okay people thinking that mike lee
wasn't a fascist is
really boneheaded um here are some of
these uh text messages
seth has uh some of them here he says
well i am
i i for one am shocked that's senator
we're not a democracy mike lee tried to
help trump overturn the election in the
name of the higher good exactly thank
you sith thank you seth exactly we're
gonna read some of these tweets um
here's here's uh some of the text on the
tweets
uh from in december of 2020
some of them are from uh some other time
periods after the election where he was
seditiously sexting mark meadows but
we'll get into that we
will get into that
on head of the week i think one of these
mark meadows mike lee are gonna show up
in bonehead of the week so we'll get
into that in the second hour
remember in the second hour gabe sanchez
our co-host and executive producer joins
us to go through the bonehead of the
week
your vote
rachel uh bittercoffer
is going to come on and talk about term
limits but here's something she says
about
inflation
hmm
you know what else drives inflation our
massive labor
shortage from trump and his maga morons
choking off legal immigration
this is why republicans shuddered over
the policy
there are now
a record five million more job openings
in unemployed people in the united
states
this is why it's so important to have
immigration folks
not just not just legal immigration
buddy illegal immigration
oh tony you're promoting illegal
immigrants
look they're migrants that come to this
country to come work
how do you [ __ ] think some of the
food gets on the your shelves how do you
think it gets done you think a bunch of
middle-class white people go out and and
to the farm fields
and work on farms get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] you can't even get
them to do a sim a simple job oh well
that's way above me
you really think that come on come on
our country and our economy is reliant
relies on migrants and immigration it
relies on it
it
relies on it
thank you rachel for your tweet
just when i yoda said i just went all
batman oh because i because i
i moved closer to the microphone no i
mean i could get a batman mask if you
guys want me to i wear batman mask why
not hell
why not
why not it is friday isn't it it's good
friday happy easter again happy easter
mj says um i hope death sant satan i
think she's talking about ron desantis
is the alpha cuck speaking of bone end
of the
week let's go back to the timeline
oh this is a good one
ron posted this photo
of uh eric greitens you guys know who
eric greitens is
this is uh this is very important race
in missouri
eric greitens is the former disgraced
criminal governor that we had here in
the state of missouri he's the guy that
stole from his own veterans charity what
a peach he is oh and by the way
not not to miss this one he duct taped
his hairdresser to a treadmill in his
basement
forced her to get naked took pictures of
her so that he could blackmail her to do
sexual acts on her ah you know little
stuff like duct taping
people to a treadmill just little things
just
little things
and here we have eric greitens who
recently has been in the news because
his ex-wife sheena has had to file
affidavits with the court to receive
custody of his children because
apparently he is abusive
apparently she is abusive
are he is abusive he abused her he
abused the children
so eric greitens calls in some kind of
faith healer here i'm not sure which one
of these [ __ ] boneheads is the faith
healer but you notice something about
this picture
do you notice something significant
something significant about this
picture something missing from this
picture
around eric greitens eric greitens is
the [ __ ] bonehead here in the middle
oh it's this guy right right there right
there that's the the former ex-criminal
governor eric greitens
and there seems to be if you look
closely here no women
not one woman standing around now there
is does seem to be maybe
maybe a woman here in the background it
looks like she's running away which i
don't really [ __ ] blame her i don't
really [ __ ] blame her that she's i
and i can't tell it's hard to tell from
here because you know maybe she's
running so fast away from these [ __ ]
psychos but apparently one of these guys
i don't know if it's a
mustache here or if it's
you know
mussolini here with the shaved head who
is the faith healer
but apparently they called in a faithy
order to exercise his demons
i think that's what ron said run said uh
what do you do when your ex-wife details
in writing prior child and domestic
abuse in the middle of your senate
campaign if you're eric writings you
calling a faith here to lay hands on you
to cast out the demons exercise the
demons
oh my god this literally you cannot make
this [ __ ] up
they couldn't find one woman to stand
here even trump even trump could find
one woman to stand here and put hands on
him
good lord not one woman not one just a
bunch of [ __ ] old crusty white
wrinkly ball sacks
good god let's give ron credit here for
this picture that he found and they
staged this picture too that's the other
thing that's crazy about this is they're
like yeah this is a good picture
this is a good idea let's do that for
our senate campaign
this guy this guy's poised to win the
republican nomination folks
he duct taped his hairdresser
naked to a treadmill in her basement
took polaroids of her
and threatened to use those as blackmail
against her unless she committed sex
acts go read it it's out there just
[ __ ] just
google eric greitens treadmill
duct taped her
you know he would say eric greitens
would probably tell you though if you
ask and i eric greitens could come on
this show eric if you're out there hey
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] idiot if you're
out there come on the show i would love
to ask you
did you really use duct tape or was it
gorilla tape because really if you think
about it if you think about it gorilla
tape would work so much better so much
better i mean you have you seen the
commercials have you seen the
commercials
it just tells you how much of a [ __ ]
bonehead that he is if he was actually
using duct tape if gorilla tape
i'm just [ __ ] kidding of course
that's how boneheaded this [ __ ] is that
this guy is running this guy's running
for senate
and there are people like yeah that's a
good idea yep the guy who tr he duct
taped the woman to a treadmill and stole
from his veterans charity that's a good
idea let's run him and he'll be the
republican holy actual [ __ ]
whoosh i said it yeah here's what i said
about the picture the he-man woman
haters club
[Laughter]
oh boy oh boy oh boy let's see what else
do we have here
what does the gabe say here for the
group that tells others to move on
and have quit twitter for parlor gab
getter and true social there sure seems
to be an obsession with staying on
twitter
that is true
and the reason why that's true let's go
to the tweety tweets and trendy trends
is i'm gonna get to it come on
come on kim and kim i think
let's see
mark cuban was trending somewhere he was
trending somewhere i know he was i've
watched it i seen it
with my own two eyes he was saying
something about the
elon musk
buying
twitter
i'll just maybe we'll have to type it in
here
mark cuban was talking about um
this is it
now
we're gonna make it in
yes one second
all right
mark cuban
this page does not exist
there we go
okay mark cuban here
here he says um my conclusion elon musk
is [ __ ] with the f at the sec his
filing with the sec allows him to stay
say he wants to take the company private
for 54 20 laugh
versus
am considering taking tesla private for
420
funding secured price go up
his shares get sold profit sec will what
the [ __ ] just happened um so mark cuban
is saying
here that it's a pump and dump scheme
just like we talked about yesterday i
said this is not serious it's not a
serious thing what elon musk is doing
you don't go
you don't go to
uh an entity like twitter and give them
an all or nothing offer this is it take
it or leave it [ __ ] that's like not a
serious thing like if you were seriously
gonna spend 43 mil billion excuse me
with a [ __ ] b 43 billion dollars on a
company like twitter
it would be a serious offer not a take
it or leave it [ __ ] you
he's just getting his people to buy
twitter stock to pump it so he can dump
the [ __ ] 9.2 percent he bought last
week
yeah he says christ it's not [ __ ]
rocket science uh so mark cuban is
trending because he's in he's in a
battle he's in a battle with uh elon
musk
which
really we need to tax the [ __ ] out of
both those guys tax the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of them uh let's see
sydney pal is trending so is trip roy
and mike lee we're gonna get to the
sexed messages
um
let's see we got a few more minutes till
rachel gets here so let's see what else
we got in the trendy trends i forget
what else we had to go through now we've
got um city pad oh it is finished that's
part of that katie porter
oh the christian smalls there's a
christian smalls um
he is the organizer for
uh the uh amazon uh union christian
smalls founder of the first independent
worker led union for amazon discusses
his work on fox news tucker carlson so
he goes on tucker carlson now i think
this is very significant
and the reason why this is very
significant is number one um he did
organize this labor union now they're
trying to drag on aoc in this clip and
i'm going to find the clip here
and they're trying to drag on it but it
there is one part in this um
uh i ain't not gonna play that
[ __ ] um
maybe this will work here
this is uh this is a clip from tucker
carlson last night
now let's see is this going to be the
actual clip or is this some kind of
let's see
i just want to make sure it's the clip
it's not some
sometimes you get in these clips and man
they just they're not what they what
they seem to be
um and i think this is
yeah this is the same one okay this is
the same one this will work let's watch
this clip here of tucker carlson and
christian smalls having it out about the
aoc and the union at amazon let's hear
it sandy cortez spends a lot of time
telling you that she's on the side of
the world
wobbly she's the walter ruther of our
day
and that's why last year she about to
stand alongside striking workers at
amazon's staten island warehouse and
we're for that
because they need the help
but did you hear that tucker carlson
says we're for that because they need
the help right
you know they'll call union socialism
and all kinds of [ __ ]
which
frankly unions aren't exactly socialism
but they're close
socialism hey if you want to know the
definition of socialism it's where the
workers it's where the workers control
the production oh how son of a [ __ ]
so let's listen to what else the shucker
tucker carlson says here
the last minute cindy quartz has bailed
on the whole thing and that infuriated
labor organizers who just want a big
vote to unionize the staten island
facility now amazon is stepping up its
effort to crush the union amazon has
just banned words like union
but it's important
why is that funny
does he i mean he's like yeah i like
that
because this [ __ ] they're
they're always they're always always
railing against unions always has been
and what people don't know
what you and maybe you don't even know
this i don't know i i think you guys are
smart enough to know this this guy on
this screen here this [ __ ] [ __ ]
here tucker carlson he's in a [ __ ]
union
he's in a union has been for a long time
been in a union chain sean hannity's in
the union laura ingrams and they're all
in unions
they're all in a union every [ __ ]
last one of them
like union's bad unions are destroying
our country i want my union benefits by
the way don't take away my union
benefits
let's listen what the this
bonehead says employee chat app oh how
how christian spalls is a union leader
at amazon and we're happy to have him
join us now christian thanks so much for
coming on he doesn't seem happy
it's almost like he didn't know that
christian was a black dude right it
almost seems like look at him he's like
whoa wait a second
i mean he usually has this confused look
but he was he seemed really confused
when christian came on the on the screen
there didn't it seem like to you
um
were you surprised that sandy cortez
alexandria ocasio-cortez
who has said repeatedly that she you
notice you notice that um
he had a backup when he said sandy
because they called her sandy um [ __ ]
idiot and then he asked us he has to
back up and say
basically say aoc which i mean you know
whatever if her friends call her sandy
or whatever the [ __ ] he wants to say
yeah whatever i call him [ __ ] tara
carlson so what's the difference she's
on the side of the worker against the
corporation wasn't standing with you at
the barricades yeah i mean you know
what's funny is she's like oh aoc enemy
because she she didn't go stand with the
workers that are against the corporation
which i'm for the corporation i
definitely namely don't want you i mean
i want my union i just don't want other
people to have unions
i don't want other folks to benefit from
unions i just want to benefit from
unions it wasn't just her it was uh all
of them pretty much you know it's not
fair you know um yeah i don't want to
make it just between us and aoc because
uh you know a lot of them didn't show up
and um you know once again we we have no
ill will against them we we know that
whether they showed or showed up or not
they didn't make or break our election
boom he doesn't go along with the
narrative it it really you can tell it's
pissing tucker girls and off here that
he's not going along with his narrative
that aoc is the enemy
because christian smalls is saying you
know it doesn't really matter it was our
election
regardless whether they showed up or not
it's our election maybe
maybe aoc understood that you dumb [ __ ]
tucker carlson just had to continue to
organize
yeah i mean it's just it's a weird
moment because i mean i'm on the right
i've never been particularly pro-union
i'm on the right i'm a fascist look i'm
a fascist christian i'm a fascist i'm a
nazi i've never been four unions even
though i is in one
i'm a fascist he admits right there that
he's a nazi
like i'm i'm on the right i've never
been four unions i'm a nazi so you've
never been four workers right you've
never been four labor organizers you've
never been for the workers always for
the corporation you mean like you just
accused aoc of doing you dumb
[ __ ] but it does seem like
amazon needs some counterbalance like
it's this huge company the workers have
no power yeah maybe we could
share a little power with people who
work there oh oh you mean like you mean
like so sh social social
little socialism
get the [ __ ] out of here that's my view
anyway so to tell us where you are in
your organizing efforts well right now
you know we're fighting for a contract
um you know amazon's disputing their
election results um so we're we're
walking and chewing bubblegum at the
same time we're fighting for a contract
we're preparing for another election in
two weeks on april 25th we're going to
be voting at a second location directly
across the building that we just
unionized so um we're in the thick of a
fight right now you know a legal battle
and um you know we just have to stay
grounded and uh pretty much uh begin our
campaign all over again uh christian
here is fantastic by the way
christian smalls
did not they thought they could bring
him on the show they thought they could
[ __ ] with him get him to say get him to
say bad [ __ ] about aoc christian smalls
did not play that [ __ ] stupid game um
and and it's beautiful that he went on
tucker carlson i think this is great
that he went on tucker carlson and
didn't give tucker what he wanted was
stupid liberal
union guy
and to blame aoc to make this some
[ __ ] story about aoc christian smalls
did not fall for that [ __ ] he did not
play that game he made it about the
workers he made it about their battle
with amazon that they're trying to get
[ __ ] decent pay in in decent [ __ ]
terms of their employment
and he didn't he didn't let up he didn't
play tucker's little game
of course he didn't and really honestly
tucker probably thought oh we'll bring
this libtard on this union libtard and
we'll own his ass which that's not the
case that's not the case christian stays
right with his narrative right with what
he has to do
so [ __ ] tucker tucker sucks uh
so good good on christian smalls i think
and keep fighting for those unions and
amazon breaking up [ __ ] amazon they
need to keep fighting amazon and these
workers need to have terms that they can
they can live with it's ridiculous that
we have we have 5 million we just seen
five million
more jobs than we have people that are
unemployed
and we want and
the economy is hot it's heated why do
you think there is inflation partly
we have we have to make sure that
workers get the terms that they have for
their employment
that we have to no matter who they are
we have to and that and speaking of that
we've seen rachel a bit of golfer had a
tweet about this earlier
and we're we're going to bring rachel on
i think she's on deck here and i tell
you what we're going to talk about when
we come back from the break we're going
to talk about
term limits and rather term limits suck
or not and are they good for democracy
so we're going to get to hear
the famous political strategist dr
rachel bittikoffer's opinion on term
limits when we come back right after
this stick with us
rachel bittikoffer right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
yours
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lib
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around for the break
know that the second hour we have
bonehead of the week we're gonna break
down your vote and we're gonna talk
about the seditious sex messaging
and mark meadow continues to roll out
but first we have rachel bittercover dr
rachel bittikover how are you rachel
i i
can't hear you i can't hear you i can't
hear you
uh-oh let's let's let rachel get there
dude
ah
there we go there we go
i think i can hear you now
you got it
well that rachel gets set up there and
just yell and scream when you're ready
there reach
and when you unmute your mic we'll get
rachel bittikoffer on here we're going
to talk about term limits um while she's
getting ready i'm going to tell you a
little bit about term limits and my
opinion on term limits here's the thing
term limits
they sound cool at first
they sound cool how are you rachel do
you get your mic
oh you just gotta unmute
damn technical problems here huh yeah it
happens it happens good morning good
morning to you good morning i was trying
to tell you all that noise in the
background was dog wrestling
oh
but luckily for me since the mic wasn't
on you didn't well there you go it
worked out perfect then it worked out
perfect so
so we're talking about term limits and i
think the reason why everyone's bringing
up term limits is because there's been
some stories out of the hill about uh
senator dianne feinstein she's 88 years
old she seems to have some cognitive
impairment
that's what people are saying that's the
stories that are going around now first
off i do want to say uh some people were
bringing up some good points about
senators or representatives in the first
place uh policymakers a lot of times a
politician is just kind of the
placeholder to get elected the policy
makers are actually their staff right so
a lot of times the staff are doing 90 80
of the work that a politician would do
so a little bit of this ah she forgets
conversations and some stuff may not be
quite as fair as people are making it
out to be um
but here's the thing with term limits
and i said this yesterday we actually
have term limits in this country
and what the term limit is is they're
limited to the number of years in their
term
we as the people get to choose
rather they get to continue to a next
term and really honestly if we would
actually participate and this is kind of
a lazy [ __ ] way
of
of us thinking about government with
term moments we're like oh well
why would we want to make sure we
participate in our democracy and know
civics and know about our government and
how it works and how it operates i don't
want to know any of that what i want to
do is make sure that the politicians
just can't be politicians forever
and it really is it's not the correct
way to thinking in democracy are you on
the same page as me or am i just the
only one
let me take us on a little abstract
metaphysical roundabout to get to like
understanding why term limits at the
federal uh level would be a bad idea
okay okay and i'm gonna do that in a
really unpredictable way because i'm
gonna talk about presidential primaries
for a second okay uh as you guys know
people [ __ ] almost as much about the
presidential primary calendar the system
that's used these individual contests
that happen over a series of a month and
a half
um and they complain about the
unrepresentativeness of iowa and and new
hampshire and then south korea you know
and then it's not fair why isn't
michigan in that is in florida if you
have been paying attention to politics
long enough you know it's triggered you
know uh wars to to on the calendar to
move up and sanctions and all kinds of
[ __ ] right and so what people say oh we
need a national primary that's what we
need we need a national primary it's not
fair that you know iowa gets to choose
our nominee everybody should vote and
everybody should vote on the same day
okay and that makes sense i mean that is
a feel-good solution that sounds like it
logically
would be an improvement but when you
think it through you start to see very
quickly it opens up a whole new basket
of different problems right so you're
exchanging one set of issues for another
at any time really that you do a reform
you get that but particularly here and
term limits are very similar
you know if you were to switch the
federal offices to term limits
number one what people should understand
is the [ __ ] that's going really wrong
in dc right now i mean they ask there
are a couple of exceptions but generally
it's because of too much turnover in the
republican party not too little right we
had a lot of states people people who
you know they were staller conservatives
but they believed in the institution of
senate of the house they believed in the
constitution they believe in the rule of
law
and they over time got purged out and
replaced with these radical wing bats
you know
so um what we see this in the state
legislatures as well instead of problems
from lifetime politicians and a lot of
them
most people are not going to become a
lifetime politician be frank okay i mean
most people don't serve six seven terms
in the senate or in the house they come
and they go faster than that and the
ones that don't are are due that are
generally serving in a state like
kentucky mitch mcconnell is
electrically inoculated from any kind of
checker mechanism to end his tenure but
generally speaking when you look at
what's [ __ ] up in the house and what's
[ __ ] up in the senate right now it's
coming from these people who were
uh brought in as replacements not the
long-timers and the long-timers
definitely have a lot of corruption
issues you know blah blah blah they
could have health issues like feinstein
uh and refused to relinquish their seat
but the one thing that they did care
about was the institution and preserving
the institution and now that is really
falling apart
well you know i i in some states there
are term limits for legislators like in
missouri in my great state of missouri
and they pass term limits on on a ballot
that the voters and the voters like oh
this is fantastic we get to make sure
that the good policy makers don't in
government anymore because that's really
the danger that you have
with
term limits like in missouri the
lobbyists run the state special interest
runs our state uh there's one guy in
particular rex syncfield who everyone
knows his name in the state because he
pretty much runs a republican party in
the state he gets to choose the
candidates and a lot of them aren't they
don't know [ __ ] about government because
here's what happens is that a legislator
goes to the state legislature like
missouri and in missouri their number
one focus and their number one policy is
the budget because they have to balance
the budget yeah a lot of these people
have no clue what a state budget looks
like they don't know have no idea and by
the time they figure it out they're not
allowed to be politicians anymore so in
other words once they once they figure
out actually how government works and
how to do the thing called uh governing
they can't be governing body anymore
they're not part of policy anymore so
then what happens is
they have to look for a job in state
politics in missouri
and to stay in politics so the natural
thing is to go to a lobbying firm so
that way they can lobby the next round
of idiots that don't know what they're
doing in government to explain to them
what they want them to pass and how they
want to do it so just because it sounds
great that your politicians
would only have a certain amount of time
to be politicians because the thing is
well if they can't get this done in this
many years then then [ __ ] them right
right right but here's the thing is that
sometimes it takes a long time and we're
never gonna stop governing we're never
gonna stop policy right it's not gonna
be like one day we're like hey the
government's perfect now everything's
great we're going to stop doing any
governing any policy we're going to stop
that stuff and besides like i mean the
only i mean
you are getting or not getting policy
out of the state legislature or the
federal one for one reason and one
reason only and that's party control or
the party breakdown the state
legislatures don't have these super
majority requirements in the senate so
they they can pass legislation without
the filibuster and they and they run
through though many of them have super
majorities anyway but you know tony
you've touched on something really
important and i'll use the federal
system to describe
think about how complex the nation is
there's so much [ __ ] going on just this
week we've got this massive
international war
problem right you've got climate change
you've got farm
prices you've got this border [ __ ] with
the supply chain right you've got so
many so much complexity in running a
government and this would be true at the
state level as well so what this so that
means is for members like a senator
can't be an expert on agricultural
policy and national security okay it's
pretty rare to find that and you need at
least some working expertise or focus
for these members because even if
they're really well versed they ran a
farm in montana or whatever
they are still going to be heavily
reliant on
the staff that's working for them but
mostly
you guys are really going to hate this
mostly on industry that they're
regulating will help them with the with
understanding the policies right
so for instance for instance the uh the
trucker thing where greg abbott is
trying to stuff up the trucker the
trucking industry has spoken out and
there's probably a lot of policy makers
uh in texas and on the hill that are
listening to industry experts on
trucking and why this is horrible for
for one instance no doubt and and you so
the more so
so even so the more you bleach expertise
from an institution a state legislature
or a federal the federal legislature
what you will end up with is a more
industry
heavy
reliance on
on somebody else i mean
if you're replacing every people people
by every two to four terms if it's a
two-year term what you have done is
wiped out all that institutional
knowledge and you're empowering the very
people that drive you the most [ __ ]
nuts which are lobbyists
right well and and because the lobbyists
are now pushing the boneheads which it
will be a bunch of boneheads in congress
because and i don't mean stupid people i
just mean people who who aren't
experienced i'll give you an example and
and maybe this will clear it up for
people is there is a special lady from
california who has a white board and i
would love to see katie porter be the
senator from california nothing would
please me more than to watch her be
senator from california until she's 400
years old and that white board is worn
down to a thread um katie porter is so
important in making policy and the
reason why is because katie porter is
very smart she's very pointed in her
questioning she's very good at it in a
committee meeting to hold private
industry accountable where they need to
be held accountable she's very
very [ __ ] good at it and i want katie
porter there not just fighting for
californians but for fighting for all
americans for those policies and if we
if we would limit her to how many terms
she could serve
she would not be there fighting for you
and there are bad politicians let's face
it there are bad politicians and i don't
just mean like crooked i just mean
they're not very good policy makers they
don't know how the legislator works they
really don't care how the legislator
works they're there for fundraising and
to be a placeholder like i was saying
before but there are politicians out
there that aren't just the placeholder
they are policy makers this is what they
do this is what they're interested in
they're interested in an area that they
aren't an expert in finding staff that
can be an expert to make sure that that
policy in that industry even though they
know nothing about it works for the
american people and also works for
american private industry because these
things go hand in hand in our country
like you're saying but the last thing we
want is for the american worker the
american people to to
get put on the back burner because
politicians cannot
do anything but
actually listen to private industry on
expertise and we need we need both we we
have to have a mixture of both
when we're making policy in this country
but it is so vitally important that our
policy makers that are the good ones
that are the great ones and most of them
we don't even know their names right
because they are actually our
policymakers they're not trying to get
on tv they're not trying to be famous
that's right yeah
do you know especially on the right are
the fire they mean madison cother didn't
even hire a policy
like chief of staff he hired a comms
person
right exactly which made sense right
because he wasn't planning on showing up
and doing it right right well he's hired
a social media manager because that's
what he is he's a social media
influencer that's exactly right but you
know here let me be fair to our
legislators though because there's many
on both sides of the aisle that do go in
there sincerely i mean you may [ __ ]
hate the policies right but they go in
there with sincere intent and that speak
but but here's the thing that people
should look this book up if they if
they're interested it's called the
electoral connection it's and it's for
people who study political science from
the behavioral perspective it is the
bible right and the reason why is
because it argues look politicians it
doesn't matter if it's the state
legislature governor federal congress
whatever they're all
single-minded
seekers of reelection or the next
election right they're moving from the
house to the senate or whatever like
that and what that means is all other
goals have to be proximate to achieving
that goal first if you don't have the
office you cannot make the policy
pursuing a banning abortion or fixing
climate change or whatever it is and so
you know even though it may look like
aoc is this purely driven
you know person for principal
it's a function of her electoral
conditions right and you could have
taken an aoc
and run her in a swing race and she
would have to behave in some ways
different i certainly wouldn't have uh
not as different as people might imagine
right but um definitely different in in
terms of like the the socialism you know
um you know cosplay i guess we'd say
right
new deal all the stuff all the stuff
that tucker carlson uses against he
calls her sandy and so like the public
looks at these politicians say like
between a um
gillibrand an aoc and it's all to them
it's just about will right it's like
what this person has principle and that
person doesn't but really
it's those electoral lines right if
you're in a safe district if you're a
joe mansion you're facing
a 35 trump point trump
differential okay so like that means
that 70 basically of joe manchin's
potential voter pool
is republican
right so like when he when he does [ __ ]
yes it might be that he owns stock and
pharma and this and that and oil
whatever by the end of the [ __ ] day
joe mentions like every other politician
except for christian cinema because from
now on we'll have to asterisk that um
and he's a single-minded seeker of
reelection what he he's doing what he
thinks gives him the most probability to
stay in the senate and continue to make
policy right so
at the end of the day guys this this
electoral connection this idea that
politicians are driven by reelection
isn't meant to make them sound
you know uh cruel or uncaring or
artificial or whatever it's just the
truth of the matter is if you if you
want to be there to make policy you have
to win and i mention all of that guys
because we already have a situation
where our members like maybe they look
like they don't do much but that's
because they're spending 40 hours a week
dialing for dollars it is so humiliating
to run or serve in any uh competitive
race now
uh seat or whatever
you have to raise so much money that
you're spending almost a full time job
on money raising every single week and
in the house that starts almost as soon
as the next session starts so senators
have it a little bit less pressured at
their six-year terms and imagine if
instead you had to
you know if you limited these house
people to two to three terms you're
resetting that fundraising operation
every time as well right so it is it is
one of those things like a national
primary if we had a national primary by
the way it's it's true that iowa would
be ignored because there's no people in
iowa right but
the presidential calendar where the
candidates go and spend money on stuff
will be in major cities major states
with major populations right so instead
you'll see all the primary love in
california in new york in texas and what
and everybody else would get the
leftovers maybe in florida right where
the big populations are because you know
in a direct primary it's just a matter
of winning that national popular vote
and how are you going to do that you're
going to do that in big populated areas
so janie brings up a comment here she
said that's bad that's why they don't
get as much done um and that is and you
know that's that's probably a good point
but also that's the point for the staff
right because that's why a lot of these
politicians rely on their staff
because they're working so hard
on
on
fundraising in some of these races that
they have to rely on their staff to make
these policies to be the policymakers
while they're the placeholder as i said
before
yeah it's terrible and it's you know
i mean imagine if you're spending 30
hours a week on call time i mean it's if
you guys have more interest in this it's
sometimes firewalled sometimes not but
60 minutes put out something about five
years ago called dialing for dollars
with david jolly actually i suppose is a
little longer now and it was his he he
just refused to do it he got into the
house from florida
realized he was going to spend 30 to 40
hours a week in buildings across so each
party has a building across the street
from capitol hill that they do this call
time in and if you've ever worked in a
phone center because i have those are
the most depressing [ __ ] environments
on the face of the earth dude like
you're in this cubicle you're on this
headset thing i mean it's [ __ ] sad so
imagine katie porter who we all love you
know sitting in this booth humiliating a
telemarketer being attacked she's
basically a telemarketer and it's our
system
of wild i mean we our electoral system
is completely [ __ ] up i mean and i
think people know that but they don't
really know it and you can't understand
it until you've done a comparative
analysis that looks at how elections get
you know done in canada or the uk even
which is the most like us or france like
that you can't just do and say whatever
the [ __ ] you want for however the
long you want to do it and based on a
pay-to-play
system where money is speech and
therefore the money to have speech and
the poor don't right so you know it is
um it is sad that our legislators are
forced to to go through this uh that
said everyone on the show understand the
reason you're not getting [ __ ] is
because the republican party is not an
honest opposition it has no interest in
governing it's never going to give us
[ __ ] it's never going to give a [ __ ] we
have to roll over them electorally
when you know that that is that is a
good point and the reason why it's a
good point is because we we as a
as an electorate cannot continue to not
pay attention and not be educated on
this stuff and that's why i say the term
that the politicians have is the term
that you choose them to have you're the
one who gets to choose that these
politicians are your politicians and to
say term limits is the answer is a lazy
way of looking at democracy as opposed
to just [ __ ] participating in it
exactly you know and in terms of like
there's always going to be i mean that's
why the republican machine is so great
there's always exceptions there's always
a couple things and if you take it and
make the whole issue defined by dianne
feinstein's declining mental health and
unwillingness to leave office then
obviously term limits are going to seem
very logical but she is an exception
most people do leave without dying in
office
you know what
it's not like professors they just die
in office right which is why there's no
jobs for phds you know but um you know
most most people do end up leaving
office there's the one the reason they
do these state funerals for the ones
that don't know
or these big deals is it is rare if it
was all of them and they couldn't do it
well in a lot of these politicians
including dianne feinstein i mean they
kind of have a lifetime appointment
right i mean
because the incumbency is the gold
standard when it comes to getting
re-elected and that's the other thing
that i think we discount um with
because a lot of people think oh well
that's a that is an actual
that's a pro a con or a pro to getting
term limits and it's like not exactly
not exactly because
actually
getting into coming out of office is a
huge statement for democracy i think a
lot of people
a lot of people discount like when eric
cantor lost his seat in a primary
like that was a huge signal in our
democracy right that was a huge signal
that the establishment was probably not
in control as much as they wanted to be
and it was it was just a preempt for
what was to come with trump it was just
this sign and and i think a lot of
people discount that just like they kind
of discount this 2022 midterm about how
important
not just the elections gonna be
for what the makeup of the house and the
senate are our governorships our
lieutenant governor some of these state
legislators the secretary of state
not just that but also the signal that
it sends to the country and to the
electorate if we reject trumpism all
across this country in the 2022 midterm
that is going to send a huge signal to
the party who is hell-bent hell-bent on
supporting putin and fascist and letting
eric greitens be the [ __ ] nominee in
in a as a state senator in their party
and possibly letting donald trump who
may be federally indicted on criminal
charges at that point run for their seat
in in the republican party as the
nominee in 2024 and and and it's not
always that they get to choose this
person but they really do they really do
they have the ability the machine has
the ability whether it's in either party
to really try to turn
a person off or turn them on and really
tear them down or prop them up and
they've been propping up donald trump
for [ __ ] six years and really you
could probably make the argument for
seven years and they continue to prop
him up and the only reason why is
because they have no proof no proof yet
that the entire country will reject
trumpism they don't see 2020 as that
proof but this midterm if we get out and
we drive the vote and we get to the
polls and we show the country not just
in in the makeup of our government but
show the country with an actual election
with actual numbers that we do not want
this [ __ ] this is all garbage we don't
want you passing laws that worrying
about gay marriage worrying about trans
children we don't want you passing walls
to try to marry children we don't want
you passing laws taking away liberty
from women and and taking away their
rights we don't want you doing that we
want you
and tell me i'm gonna interrupt because
i'm so glad you set that up okay because
you're exactly right we don't want that
and i want to leave the convo with this
imagine if we fail imagine if we just
get rolled over this fall what [ __ ]
message has that sent because you just
went through a laundry list a litany of
you know authoritarian
light at least
tracks that the gop is taking in the
states and if we fail to hold them to
account this fall
then they're gonna have
red license i mean it's just gonna be
a [ __ ] field day of of autocratic
[ __ ] coming from this republican
party not just in congress we're gonna
see that we're gonna see them come hard
they're gonna investigate nancy pelosi
they're going to investigate joe biden
it's going to be oh it's going to be
[ __ ] complete [ __ ] abuse of the
investigation and they don't and they
aren't like us they're going to do ever
they're going to pull every [ __ ]
media trick they can pull they're going
to you know you know refer for criminal
charges any time they can they don't
they don't pull punches and so you know
when you mention you know
the stakes and how important it is think
about the opposite message if we fail
think about what it is said to them so
it basically gives them an open invite
to end democracy
absolutely and and that's why we have to
drive the vote it's not just about
winning these races um even even in
these in these places where we're safe
in these congressional races where we're
safe you have to get out and you have to
vote because you have to prove to the
country
send a message it is so clear the
message just like the reason why the
reason why the world is so receptive to
joe biden is because he won by eight
million votes because i truly do not
believe that 81 million people voted for
joe biden and a lot of people hear that
and they say well wait a second i say
there was a lot of those 81 million that
voted against trumpism they voted
against trumpism and that is so
important to see that that it's not just
about picking one politician or one
party over the other it really is about
being pro-democracy and standing on that
mantle of the democracy and saying this
is what we're going to protect we're
going to protect it and right now in our
country there is only one party just one
that is willing to protect your liberty
willing to protect our democracy protect
your freedom and your rights full stop
and there is another party that is
hell-bent on taking it away from you if
they don't like who you are if you're
the other and that is fascism and it is
at our doorstep it is the threat and
don't think it will not come for you it
will it they're coming after women's
uteruses they're coming after children
right now they want to marry them they
want to they want to take consent away
from parents and they're starting with
trans kids with this consent thing but
they're doing it and they'll continue to
do it every
red state and every red legislator wants
to out florida florida at this point i
think what do you think rachel i think
you're exactly right and i have a 10
o'clock meeting
hey rachel thank you for joining us
everyone stick around everyone uh go
follow rachel on twitter at rachel
bittikofford thank you doc thanks for
joining us thanks for talking
tournaments we'll talk to you soon
stick around right we'll be right back
right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots
what would you do if there was a trump
supporter right in front of you crying
in pain because they have to live under
communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around
rachel did a cougher doctor rachel
giving us
giving us her views
of term limits oh nice to see i'm i'm
still
oh you know me there we go there we go
rachel's banner's now off you know i'm
just i'm i'm getting used to this we're
trying to get bonehead of the week
together here
we will bring you bonehead of the week
as soon as we get the uh the graphics
ready we're working on those
i think this term limit thing you know a
lot of people want to uh go uh against
the grain here on this term limit thing
and missouri let me kind of explain in
missouri and i kind of talked about this
yesterday
what happens is
in the state of missouri they they
passed a referendum in the 1990s people
voted for it the people voted for it
they're like yay term limits
bad politicians gone right we want them
gone well but when you get rid of the
bad ones you get rid of the good ones
okay and a great example of that is
katie porter
um how great would it be if dianne
feinstein decides to retire and gavin
newsom appoints katie porter as the
senator of california now i'm not saying
that's going to happen
but i'm just saying that's a possibility
that's a true possibility
what that would give is katie porter the
incumbency
of her next election which would
probably be a special election
to reelect the senator of california
because she would be appointed senator
of california this is all hypothetical
but that would give her the incumbency
right
now
in term limits
depending on how long that term is that
may be part of her term her appointment
why would you want that why would you
want her to serve a half a term
okay the other the other point is is
that katie porter
is not 90. she's not 90 now and like i
said earlier
with rachel
i would prefer if katie porter was the
center of cal senator of california
i want her to be the senator of
california until she's 400 years old and
that white board is worn down to a
thread
i'm not [ __ ] you that is important
because katie porter's just not good at
asking questions in a committee meeting
right if you follow her on on on
anything really not just not just the
viral videos that she has on her
questioning and it's only because that
katie porter knows what the [ __ ] she's
doing when it comes to policy for the
people that's the most important part
when you watch katie porter when you
watch what she says you watch the
questions that she asked she's asking
those questions for the people
and that is a good policy maker for
americans
and it's important to rebut the
politicians that are there for corporate
america because there are some
politicians in washington that think
they represent their constituents but
really represent corporate america
and when you have term limits
like rachel was saying a lot of the
expertise now falls on private industry
on corporate america
to give those politicians the expertise
that they need to make decisions on
policy
do you really want private corporations
through lobbyists do you really want
private corporations through special
interest groups running your policy they
do here in missouri
and it's [ __ ] terrible
it's [ __ ] terrible
it's a horrible situation
for the state of missouri
for the politicians to be run by lobby
groups and really that's all running for
politics for the state legislator
here in missouri is
is all you are is a farm for a higher
office or a farm for a lobby firm
that's it that's all it is
it's a farm for lobbying firms so they
can lobby the next group of idiots that
get elected and i don't mean that
they're stupid i mean
a lot of them are
like here in missouri most of them are
republicans so they're [ __ ] boneheads
but here's the thing
is that they don't know how to govern
they don't know how a legislator works
they're not really sure how the staff
works they don't know
a lot of these people aren't in
government before they come to state
government
and they're being farmed by the
lobbyists to do that now when you have a
politician
like katie porter not specifically but
like katie porter who is a politician
for the people who cares about the
policy that this country makes
for the average working people and her
constituents and not just her
constituents but americans in general
when you have a politician that cares
about that
and who sets policy that's good for the
people you want to make sure that
politician stays there
and fights for those policies and
continues to fight and continues to
fight and the reason why
the reason why
is because we have to maintain our
democracy and that's what does it
the other thing too about some of the
things that rachel was saying about the
fundraising
the only way to change
how our fundraising works in this
country make sure that we when we have a
good policymaker like katie porter she's
not across the street being a
telemarketer
the way to do that is not to elect the
the fascist
that's not that's not how to do it
the way to do it is to keep electing
pro-democracy people that are going to
set policy that are good for americans
do you think it is good for americans
average working americans who elect
their politicians do you think it's good
for them
to have a politician who sits across the
street with a headset on and has to
raise money every [ __ ] day because if
they don't they won't be your politician
and they won't be able to get into the
fight for you
what do you think do you think that's a
good idea for americans of course it's
not
i'm sure almost every single politician
and on the hill
would prefer
the good policy makers
the bad policy makers want to raise
money
like madison catherine marjorie taylor
greene lauren bobert
ted cruz josh hawley that's that's that
that's why they're a politician is to
raise money
that's why they are not there to set
policy they don't give a [ __ ] about
policy they don't
they don't they don't give a [ __ ]
suzanne from youtube says
when kate asked a question she's already
knows the answers that's right
katie porter is very well prepared and
part of that is her staff but she is
super smart
she knows the policy she is she is one
of us right like there is no other
better example
of an average american becoming a
congresswoman than katie border
very very important that we keep those
policy makers in our government
not push them out because we don't we
want to be lazy because really honestly
to set term limits for politicians is on
us
that's on us that's us being [ __ ]
lazy inside our democracy it really is
it's us being [ __ ] lazy the
electorate
being [ __ ] lazy that we don't that we
don't want to have to [ __ ] figure out
who's a good one who's a bad one just
get rid of all of them just get rid of
all of them after a certain point let
them circulate
just have that rotating door that way we
don't have to do work to figure out
who's good and bad
because the hell with the good as long
as we don't have the bad for too long
then we'll be okay that's really [ __ ]
lazy of us
the electorate
that's why you have these politicians
always going yeah we're for
who who don't have term limits they're
like yeah we're for term limits yeah
sure
as if they're gonna pass term limits the
united states
house of representative is not gonna
pass term limits on themselves
they're not going to
and there is no referendum in this
country the only referendum we have is
to elect our congress member that's the
only referendum there's no national
whenever you ever went into a ballot box
and and voted on a national referendum
win have you ever no because we live in
a constitutional
democratic republic
we elect people to go represent our vote
but you have to do your job
and you
you have to make sure that you're doing
the research that you can do to make the
best vote possible
and right now
unfortunately it really is unfortunate
and i'm not making this up it is really
unfortunate that in this country we only
have one party
that is even remotely
even
remotely willing
to stand with democracy but that's just
the way it is
and i had someone yesterday because i
said that that
politicians and united states senators
already have term limits um and you know
and i i'm skating around definitions of
words of course but the conversation is
important
so when you're talking to someone about
term limits right we always talk about
messaging here if you're talking to
someone about term limits tell them tell
them this and you're going to argue back
and forth
the [ __ ] definition of term limit and
the definition of term
tell them we already have term limits we
get to limit their term how many terms
they serve we get to limit it us
the voters it's a democracy
and that is the most important message
that we need to send
um is that it is a democracy
it is a democracy uh wait ho ho holy
moly who do we have here
our co-host executive producer gabe
sanchez gabe you must have uh
is your mic on
it is on oh my gosh look at there he's
running his mic
he's got his mic going today this is
fantastic this is fantastic i'm almost
done getting your
your graphics uploaded no thank you yeah
yeah so what do you think about the term
limits what's your opinion on the terms
maybe you have a different opinion than
me
uh my opinion is look i i look at people
who
are like katie porter and i'm like
she [ __ ] kills it right she's not
going to be the candidate that's going
to run for the presidency but she is the
candidate who
do you want i mean i i wouldn't be
against katie being president or do you
want katie not questioning people in
congress or in the senate no no no i i
mean i i i think for someone you know
like she is uh
revolutionized the white board let's
just say i i think she's one of the
smartest politicians that well totally
yeah yeah totally i think that you know
she is uh she is
in her own league when it comes to stuff
she's like in terms of cross-examination
she is top
notch she gets the job done in terms of
turn like in terms of term limits uh i
would have to say like i i could make
the case
i
i think there are more bad cases of
representatives you know congress people
and also senators than there are good
people
and so you're saying sure you're saying
more politicians are bad than good and
do you mean crooked or bad because when
i talk about i mean incompetent i mean
crooked i mean sure you know shady
whatever they are like you know there
are people in there who haven't done
[ __ ] right like even if you haven't
passed a bill you know at least bring
something to the table right like
if you're like jim jordan and you have
just
disregard for your constituents you
haven't passed a single bill and all of
the time that you've been there you're
uh you know a walking uh creep
um you know i look at those things and
not to say that they're not illegal but
i do look at those things and i say are
you the best
representative for the people there
right are you competent enough have you
been properly vetted and when i say
vetted too like you know obviously
there's due diligence that happens from
uh running but also like
as in your tenure of being a
representative or you know whoever you
are in terms of a legislator you know
that being your vetting process say like
oh
in the 5 10 whatever years you were here
or
you know you've been here for [ __ ] 30
plus 40 years or whatever like what have
you done what have you co-signed what
have you sponsored what have you written
yourself what have you actually passed
what committees are you on what are you
actually doing and a lot of that stuff
you probably don't get insight into
because it's like you know televised on
c-span and c-span ain't sexy baby so
when i look at this i i say
i'm for tournaments only because we've
seen term limits abused
by shady crooked incompetent uh people
who are representing their constituents
and they say oh well you know what i'm
undisputed no one's running against me
this is a shoeing i'm just gonna stick
around i'll get my benefits i'll get my
pension i'll get my you know six figure
pay i'll get my interns i'll get my you
know
uh travel spike stipend i'll get my you
know uh housing out here in dc
you know i look at that i'm like there
are a lot of benefits for people who
don't do [ __ ] you know
um well and i i'll tell you that that
that is a really good point um because
she was talking about madison cawthorne
because madison gothard isn't a member
of congress like he doesn't go
you know yeah he's he's a social media
influencer like right like rachel said
rachel said he didn't hire he didn't
hire uh a uh
like like a chief of staff he hired a
comms person like a social media manager
right right and keep in mind that cops
person was also the one who said hey you
know what we should do we should let
everyone know that you're getting a
divorce and made it an official
statement
you know on
on social media like
listen i don't care what's going on in
your personal life that's no excuse for
what's going on if you feel like you
need to step away from the office by all
means do that
but in terms of sharing that information
and then getting upset at people for
coming at you for sharing that
information or something about your
relationship or whatever it is like i
don't know i like it so when madison
cawthorne uh
uh when when madison cawthorne um shared
that from the comms guy i was like is
this
is this really what we should be doing
right now like is this the best thing
like it's you know whether you want to
keep your your your personal
situation private or not you know it's
i don't know if that was a means of like
letting people know getting sympathy or
or just being like i want to get ahead
of the story before they find out that
i was actually uh
uh taken over by a russian spy i don't
know if that's true right right but what
i'm just saying well you know the other
thing about madison gawthorne is that
um
they they are like fundraisers
but not in the sense of like katie
porter sitting in a
phone booth like rachel was describing
like if katie border's so important to
my our democracy and she's such a good
congresswoman why would you want her
going across the street and sitting for
30 hours trying to raise money and being
telemarketer why would you want that and
and so
it is upon us
the the the term limit thing and the
term limit talk is as i believe that
it's
us as an electric being lazy and not
taking responsibility for what we have
to do
which is make sure we're participating
in our democracy and knowing the civics
knowing the government and really and
really participating in this democracy
not just not just paying attention or
bitching on twitter i mean actually
figuring out like who your school board
people are who your state legislator the
governor the lieutenant governor i mean
so many people can't even tell you who
this who sits on the city council or the
county commission where they're at right
they have no idea no clue or the school
board which all that is part of our
democracy and all that is important
because if we elect more pro-democracy
people i truly believe that one of these
days we may have public uh campaign
finance reform where we don't we we do
not have a situation where what that we
have now with citizens united we don't
have a supreme court made up like we do
now where they're bought and paid for on
the right wing not to overturn people's
liberty i i think that if we keep
pushing and we keep pressing this
pro-democracy thing i think we can do
that here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna go to break
you you're good on break we're gonna go
to break we're gonna go to break and
then when we come back um we'll we'll go
into bonehead of the week don't stick
around we'll be right back after this
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
i think we're gonna do bone end of the
week
well then you got your your mic muted
again you know oh it happens it happens
it happened
i was doing so good
i know okay so let's let's see if we can
get the switch made here uh because i
think i think if someone did it right oh
oh look at that
wow look at that oh look at it
let's let's go to um let's see should we
go to this view there we go
that looks more like bonehead of the
week doesn't there we look at the new
banner everybody look at that see now
the transition is like it just shifts
slightly in color you know just slightly
color for bone hand of the week so we
got some good candidates but let's start
let's start the sound let's start the
sound so we all know we're starting
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week boy we have some great things
that we're going to do today but the one
thing i want to do there's even there
there is even uh
one of the candidates
there has been an update in the last
three minutes oh has there really so
you're keeping an eye on the news yeah
in the news uh well let's let's go to
the candidates here and let's not waste
a lot of time we have the governor greg
abbott uh elon musk and charlie kirk um
obviously there's a lot of
fanfare i guess you'd say i don't know i
don't know i guess maybe that you'd say
over some of these elon musk just can't
stop uh we can't stop talking about this
[ __ ] he bought nine percent of the
company uh of twitter then he wants to
buy twitter mark cuban this morning is
claiming he's doing a pump and dump
which is my belief did he say i thought
he said that yesterday the day before he
but yes essentially he he um he's saying
he's driving up the price he's driving
yeah he's driving same thing he did with
tesla and it all trying to do it before
the sec is like wait what the [ __ ] is
going on you know right right exactly
well and and i mean
honestly i said this yesterday
the fact that the fact that elon musk
was like take it or leave it is it's not
a serious thing like when you're talking
about
43 billion dollars a take it a lever
take it or leave it offer is not going
to be viewed seriously in any boardroom
across right well i mean here's the
thing the things that i've seen on the
right they're like oh okay again let's
go back to the group of people on the
right who say i'm getting off twitter
because it's suppressing my my voice
it's silencing me uh i need to have my
freedom of speech and they're
restricting my my my first amendment
right which is none of that is true okay
uh you could say dumb [ __ ] you could say
stupid [ __ ] you could say a bunch of
rather just terrible dumb takes right uh
you could be bigoted whatever now you
can say those things it doesn't remove
any sort of consequence from the action
that you took right so if that is in
regards to your job employer employees
friends family whatever they push you
aside and say
we don't want to be affiliated with you
that's not twitter's fault that is your
fault you did that you did that to
yourself you dragged yourself through
the mud and the [ __ ] and everything and
then now that you're all a mess you're
like wait wait this is not fair what's
going on you did it you did it to
yourself okay just understand that there
are consequences to the actions you take
okay it's consequence culture it's not
cancel culture
now these people on the right
who claim these things and i'm going to
gab and i'm going to get her and i'm
going to choose social i'm going to
parlor and i'm going to rumble and i'm
going to whatever the other [ __ ] dumb
websites that they go to where they say
that the the freedom of speech is
unrestricted and we can do whatever they
want who rob we can be as racist and
terrible
here's the thing
those people
100 of the time are on twitter stay on
twitter despite the fact that they go
there's gonna be a mass exodus they set
it for all of these different apps right
all of the different apps and what it
ends up being they come back to
[ __ ] on twitter on twitter because they
can't get away they want twitter so
badly despite the fact that they're
saying they're going to leave in a mass
exodus and they're going to go to these
these right-wing first amendment
prohibits because they need it it's
because they need it right they need it
i mean i mean look at marjorie taylor
green she's a perfect case study she
loses her personal account but she's
still and she goes out and she's like i
was banned from twitter like she wears
this badge and she's still tweeting on
her her [ __ ] congressional account
yeah like she speaks every [ __ ] day
on her congressional account exactly so
she didn't leave twitter and she didn't
get kicked off twitter i mean she
probably should be there's a good case
that she should be but it's her
congressional account and she knew that
paul goes are the same way he would
cheat tweet crazy [ __ ] from his
congressional account because he well
from his congressional because he knew
that they wouldn't [ __ ] ban right
right so which is which is uh you know
obviously
is you know i i don't know there's a lot
of like uh what's allowed and you know
in terms of like a government official
and things like that like i i think
there should be some sort of like hey
this tweet is [ __ ] uh homophobic well
i i mean i mean transphobic right you
know like margie taylor green had video
last like two weeks that was i was
pushing transphobic messaging and uh
and twitter was like this is fine well i
don't i don't think i don't think
twitter has to permaban no no no no an
official account like like a
representative i think they can just
they can they can hide tweets if they
need to hide them
you know what they could do as well is
they could just suspend them from having
any uh any activity to where it's just
like an archive like they can't right
tweet they can't post you can just read
it right you can just read the archive
right so speaking speaking of um uh
people who were who have been suspended
from twitter charlie kirk is also on the
list i don't want to spend a lot of time
on this guy because i really want to
move forward to greg abbott and our
dishonorable mention today um
but charlie kirk he said tall buildings
are liberal is that is that kind of how
you he
he's like oh the taller the building the
more liberal it is
i believe what he was saying is he was
saying black people live in tall
buildings and that's why tall buildings
are bad white people live in nice
suburban houses with big yards and
that's why they're good that's what
yeah i mean yes he could very well make
the case of like uh oh you're in a city
and certain demographic is stacked on
each other in buildings and whatnot i
mean like his also his other argument
was like if you're conservative you're
out in the land your hands are you're
you're sowing the seeds and you're
working the
this is okay
hold on where did charlie kirk grow up
let's look at this ready
let's look at this i would imagine he
grew up with the dirt under his
fingernails i mean and he grew up in
arlington heights illinois which is a
suburb of chicago oh really do you know
where arlington heights illinois is yeah
yeah yeah it's over by valentine it's
it's like a little south uh you're
you're saying it's like a rural farming
where they actually grow food and the
only food they eat is the food they're
in there no no no no no no no no it's uh
so it there's chicago and then it's it's
uh it's right it's a suburb right yeah
northwest yeah yeah so it's over by like
you know schaumburg and schaumburg
palentine hoffman estates like all these
places are cookie cutter homes they're
all like
uh you guys
you you mean big houses with nice big
yards with a lot of white yeah you know
a lot of cul-de-sacs a lot of
cul-de-sacs right they don't want people
coming in again right people know
anything about cul-de-sac history on
them uh but
that's the type of town that he grew up
in and also if you look at those the
town that he grew up in like the highest
building you're gonna have commercial
buildings there i mean they're not gonna
be skyscrapers but they're gonna be
20 30
like floors right
so for this guy also uh a big fan of
trump and i'm pretty sure he said trump
built tremendous or magnificent
buildings right so well we went through
this yesterday and really honestly he's
like trump i i said this yesterday like
if charlie kirk would have left the
podium and donald trump came up right
after him he would be like i build the
tallest best buildings ever the mo the
glorious department's the best right
most fantastic i mean he would brag
about how tall his buildings are right
yeah and they and the people in the
crowd would clap they say yeah
for how buildings are liberal but the
thing is and the reason why here's why i
said this yesterday the reason why those
people clap so hard in the audience and
they would clap for trump is because
they knew what charlie was saying
charlie was saying we want more white
neighborhoods with nice suburbia white
neighborhoods with less with less people
of color right in them and we want the
people of color to be in the big tall
high-rises quote-unquote ghettos because
that's that's what they were clapping
right i mean you remember trump during
the during the campaign was saying like
oh they're gonna ruin now whoever you
know they are will just use it very
loosely as anyone who's not white is
going to ruin the suburbs right you know
the cory bookers right trump said
uh
those black dudes right right like
you know his you couldn't be more more
right the dog whistle was pretty clear
that was there right uh but yeah it's
the same type of stuff like trump saying
like oh suburbs would be ruined because
they're gonna be like no no that's not
how it goes look our suburban housewife
he would say suburban housewife like
yeah you do you realize that most of
suburbia they're not housewives they
work because they have to afford to live
there right what are you [ __ ] talking
about there's not that many households
in this country anymore with one income
they're just not right it's not a thing
that exists as much speaking of
households and married couples and you
know rather they get along or
they arouse each other um our our alpha
guck of the week is ben shapiro
like that photo i found oh my god that's
fantastic it actually looks like it
actually looks like him having the
conversation with his wife about what a
whop is and what a dap is right so
you're telling me um
it's not supposed to be dry
oh my god so as everyone knows um and if
you if you want you can go to our
youtube channel please subscribe to the
youtube channel uh we put up a video of
me and gabe breaking down uh ben shapiro
and why he was punked basically by a
student
um should we play this video one more
time
with give context because here's the
thing even even if they already know the
context the video's still funny right
it's well and it's like what it's like
11 seconds long yeah i mean this is this
is
listen it's probably longer than shapiro
in bed
[Music]
oh okay so let's play the video here
this is what happened he was at some
kind of a fascist talking thing event
and uh a student got handed the
microphone and listened to what the
student says uh be be very very clear on
what the student says we'll play it once
export yeah which i literally that i use
throughout the speech not generally you
sound like a bozo and you get no [ __ ]
and you can't even make your wife wet
bro so what's good
i mean i think i think we should have
renamed uh this one to bozo of the week
bozo of the week that goes over the week
but the reason why he's the alpha cuck
of the week is not necessarily
not necessarily why he got alpha cuck of
the week here because he did get kind of
get cucked here but the reason why is
because ben shapiro kind of told on
himself a couple years ago when he was
totally offended totally offended by
cardi b song
[ __ ] which stands for wet ass [ __ ] for
those who don't know um because that's
important because he claimed that there
is no such thing as a wet ass [ __ ] that
cardi b was uh operating in fiction
because his wife has told him that that
doesn't exist
that she doesn't get
aroused like that and her vagina does
not do that thing and he kind of told on
himself that right he dries up the room
when he walks in what do you what did
you think i said ben shapiro sucks the
moisture out of the room right when he
walks in right right when he's like ben
shapiro opens doors like
everyone just like is like so
like right
and just like leather skin
[Laughter]
so that's why that's why ben shapiro is
the alpha cook of the week so like
congratulations to ben shapiro on on
gaming around this is the first time by
the way this is the first time he's been
on the show really actually on bone end
of the week
congratulations to ben give him a round
of applause
oh yeah that's fantastic so if you guys
want to go watch that clip um go to our
youtube channel and you'll find the ben
shapiro uh clip of me and uh gabe
talking about uh
whopping wet ass [ __ ] it's fantastic
and you get to see gabe's impersonation
of
ben shapiro which is also fantastic um
but this moves me to our dishonorable
mention which i really want to focus on
our bone of the week winner uh we'll
give him his due but i really want to
focus on this story because this is the
story of the day
mark meadows is this the one that you're
saying there's some updates in the land
no no no the one that i'm referring to
is elon musk oh okay so yeah let's let's
move let's go to that verse let's give
us the elon musk news here and then
we'll go to uh mark meadows chip roy
and um uh
senator mike lee all sexting each other
seditiously sexting just so what's the
elon musk news so they responded i just
saw that uh
that twitter twitter responded twitter
responded and
um
yeah it's just like
okay so basically uh the the ap news
article says twitter adopts a poison
pill defense in musk takeover bid
uh twitter said friday that its board of
directors has unanimously adopted a
poison pill defense in response to a
tesla ceo elon musk's proposal to buy
the company to take it private they said
the move formally called a limited
duration shareholder rights plan aims to
enable its investors to realize the full
value of their investment by reducing
the likelihood that any one person can
gain control of the company without
either paying shareholders a premium or
giving the board more time poison pills
are often used as defense against
hostile takeovers which happens all time
at companies where some person you know
gets up majority and then or has the
majority stake within the the company
and then tries to push out people or or
assign a new board of directors or
executives
under their own kind of direction
and says twitter's plan would take
effect if musk's roughly nine percent
stake grows to 15 or more even then musk
could still take over the company with a
proxy vote by voting uh out the current
directors twitter said the plan doesn't
prevent the board from engaging with
parties or accepting an acquisition
proposal if it's in the company's best
interest uh twitter had revealed its
security filings thursday that musk
offered to buy the company outright for
more than 43 billion saying that social
media platform needs to be transformed
as a private company in order to build
trust with its users i i don't know if
that's necessarily true you know but
that's musk's idea and it goes and then
he's saying [ __ ] about i believe in
free speech there is free speech on
twitter you [ __ ] right yeah right well i
mean here's the thing is really honestly
uh twitter's free speech only your free
speech on twitter only extends to how
much uh twitter is willing to let you do
that right exactly you could you could
say ridiculous you you you could post
the most insane
vile disgusting bigoted
homophobic transphobic racist uh
whatever you wanted to post as long as
they'll leave it there it's yeah now
here's the thing now whether or not
other people look at that and say
this is [ __ ] up and then report you
and then twitter says ah yeah that's
pretty messed up it violates
our private companies
terms of service
that you agree to you click the little
boxes i agree with the privacy policy
the terms of service yes i want to
create an account there's community
guidelines to make sure that doesn't
just [ __ ] go into the craziness
so if other people report you or there's
some sort of uh
you know like moderation aspect of it
that's on you because you posted
something that was against the thing
that you agreed to right right so don't
worry don't get mad at other people if
you want to post that racist [ __ ] if you
really want to post that racist [ __ ] on
the internet go start your own website
you can post it on there yeah you can
you can post it on i i hate
freespeech.com or whatever you want go
buy go buy you a [ __ ] website over at
godaddy and you can just start posting
and posting posting you don't have the
right to [ __ ] for everyone to see
your racism just because you want them
to on twitter's website that's not how
it works uh thank you to mj she gave us
a super chat here for
the no wet ass [ __ ] bozo she said hey
and then uh tony tony thank you for the
super chat and we have gaby here with
the super sticker thank you away baby
for the super chat the super stickers
here on bonehead of the week if you want
to get in on the super chat go subscribe
to the youtube channel you can do
super chat
subscribe um during the show
um so the the remaining part here so
there was a video that was yesterday uh
later on thursday during an onstage
interview at ted 2022 conference he went
on musk went on even broader having a
public platform that is maximally
trusted and broadly inclusive is
extremely important to the future
civilization
musk revealed in a regulatory filings
over recent weeks that he'd been buying
twitter shares in almost daily batches
starting january 31st like so this is
not again for people this guy this year
he didn't just like outright buy nine
percent he was strategically buying
stuff little in little like breadcrumb
increments right to get himself to a
point because where he can see now the
poison building you're saying what
facebook is doing it sounds like what
they're doing is making sure that a
billionaire can't yeah excuse me yeah
twitter is making sure that a
billionaire can't just come in and
destroy their company right they're
putting in a condition to say like oh if
he gets over this percentage then you
know
then this you know poison pill goes into
effect but that's the defense that
they're making right now which is like
they want to prevent anyone because they
see they see what he wants to he wants
to
do
yeah yeah again he's not wanting to save
twitter he's wanting to destroy it right
right and so you know if it's like he
really wanted to create something
himself i mean here's here's the other
thing like obviously like elon musk has
created companies but everyone's like oh
tesla tesla he didn't start tesla he
came in as an investor and then took it
over when he realized that people the
original two co-founders uh after it
started gaining popularity they weren't
talking about they weren't mentioning
him because it was he was just an
investor he wasn't the one behind the
ideas right and he got and then he you
know took him he pushed him out and well
i i man i get this all the time when i
knock on elon musk on a clip or some
[ __ ] they're like oh
he invented the electric car i'm like
[ __ ] this is a guy who's got a
silver spoon from blood diamonds in
south africa
and and and yes is he smart is he does
he know market sure whatever he he might
know but but you [ __ ] in-cell people
out there who thinks he's some kind of
[ __ ] self-made brainiac genius you
are full of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah he's not
self-made he is not a genius i can tell
you i know i have friends who have
worked
at tesla i have a another friend who is
a literal rocket scientist
wait wait wait wait wait an actual one
not like an actual one like an actual
rocket scientist right at spacex and
i've heard stories from both of them
where they have told me that
here's the thing
elon is good at absorbing like snippets
of of not like info right he can he can
learn about something and discuss it to
an extent however
he's not a genius he's not my god
you're blowing our minds that he's not a
rocket scientist sorry i really i really
thought i really thought when he wrote
when he gets his space dildo in the
space i really thought that that meant
that he was the actual one
like tony starking it like he's building
it in his basement and yeah he's
everyone wants to be iron man but he is
not iron man i know it's so
disappointing it's so disappointing
speaking of just go ahead go ahead oh so
the last thing it says after musk
announced his stake twitter quickly
offered him a seat on the board of the
condition that he would be limit his
purchase do no more than 14.9 of the
company's outstanding stock but the
company said five days later that must
get declined so this is when he
initially uh was given a board seat
right because he doesn't actually want
to do work he doesn't want to yeah he
doesn't want to do this [ __ ] he wanted
to get in there and make the changes he
want whatever it might be they know
they know he wants to destroy twitter
they know it they know exactly the
writing's on the wall
well let's move to let's move to the
story of the day uh i'm here to mark
meadows oh kelly thank you for the
superhero thank you for the super
sticker kelly let's move to the um to
the uh story of the day which is we
dishonorable mention here is mark
meadows and it really seems like mark
meadows phone
was completely open and i don't know if
he was like advertising it out there on
like
on like dating websites or something but
he was receiving a ton
a ton of
sex messaging oh yeah i mean it wasn't
just it wasn't just don jr or
i mean these people he had a whole slew
from uh of trumpers that were really
really really into tearing down when you
say trumpers let's clarify these are
people
close within the circle
or uh within the the trump um uh kind of
network either representative senators
or those within the actual white house
so that's something that uh that people
need to know here is like it's not just
like oh it was texting with some like
trump supporters it was like no these
are people with actual like voting power
right and have actual influence in
politics which is
so who are who are these people because
i want to bring this i'm going to bring
this up here
so remember today we have two people in
the news other than mark meadows right
so the original remember the original
text that came out during the january 6
committee um was
sean hannity laura ingraham
uh don jr
and
um
what's his face from uh
from um from batman no i meant the joker
is that who was no no i mean who knows
uh though i think the joke would be like
dude not my style
so
so oh the other one was uh what's his
face from the um
fox and friends yeah i forget his name
yes so those are the original it was
like why why is mark meadows why does
mark meadows have a direct line into
these
uh entertainment correspondents let's
call it what it is not news
correspondents entertainment
correspondents
then
texts get announced that uh there are
ones between mark meadows and jenny
thomas and you're like whoa whoa jenny
thomas that's the wife of supreme court
justice clarence thomas
what is going on here and we already
know that well and not to mention
not to mention she's texting him queuing
on stuff like this just wasn't like
right this wasn't just let's overturn
the election like she was down deep
inside
the the q anon base like she was writing
facebook and just regurgitating
she was deep in that hole that sounds so
good which which really which really
these texts that we're seeing today are
kind of different
to overthrow the government of the
united states like right he's really
he's not using conspiracy theories as
much he actually is knocking conspiracy
theorists like sydney powell saying oh
this is this is bad if we want to
overturn this election sydney powell and
q anon is really awful if we want to
make sure we subvert the constitution
here right like he's making that case to
mark meadows so mark meadows just wasn't
receiving the q anon theory right he was
receiving rebuttals like hey if you want
to overthrow the government right we
need to stop playing around with these q
and a like right right
just the fact that that it wasn't just
like hey man
like let's let's just let the process
work itself out let's not try to
uh
cause some sort of like
block or or try to um
to to prevent it from happening you know
it really was like yeah let's let's try
to stop this [ __ ] right uh because
that's what was happening and here's one
here it says from mike lee to mark
meadows these are from cnn.com these are
the text messages i'm sure gabe will be
doing a uh another text messages from i
just did one with don junior that was
another one that came out where don
junior was like we've got control we own
the states right trump's gonna do
whatever we want and that was before
january 6th and before and after the
election too right so here's from mike
lee to mark meadows we're sending this
as a private communication from us to
him through you we are not issuing it as
a press release um and then also use it
however you deem appropriate like
however you want to overthrow the
constitution just do that
you know and it and here's it goes on
and if it's helpful to you for you to
leak it feel free to do so question mark
mark man is like what wait a second what
you want me to leak my text messages
this information um and here's where he
kind of starts knocking on sydney pal
cindy powell is saying that she needs to
get in to see the president but she's
being kept away from him apparently she
has a strategy to keep things alive but
several states pay are back in play can
you help get her in so this is where
he's kind of on her side right but later
on after she does the press conference
let me find that spot the press
conference where rudy giuliani's hair
starts leaking yes and sydney pal starts
talking craziness right that's that's
that is when everyone went [ __ ] crazy
for the kraken right uh the kraken
the biggest flop in human history right
because that's what she was talking
about voting machines and hugo chavez
and who had been overused yeah yeah that
was great that was right so this is
november uh 19th after this press
conference um and this is from lee to
meadows i'm worried about the pal chris
so he was for her talking to the
president yeah now he's like oh my god
she's a [ __ ] crazy is this after when
was that conference was it after
november i'm not real sure but he says
i'm worried well you might check that
i'm worried about this press conference
um mike lee says potential defamation
liability for president is significant
here um and that's because she was
making pressing comments about dominion
and stuff that were not [ __ ] true and
now we see a defamation suit against her
and rudy giuliani and mike lindell and
others but mike lee says for the
campaign and for the president
personally saying that this is
significant and it's going to damage the
campaign and the president personally uh
in other words mike lee seen this as a
threat um to their you know reputation
so going back to november 19th he
watched that press conference and then
sent that text as it was happening oh so
so it this he's texting this to mark
meadows the press conference was on
november 19th which means he started
watching he was like oh [ __ ] is off the
rails
and we don't have time stamps here so it
may be right there or right right yeah
yeah because here's what's happening
they're making all these claims
and then obviously uh you know this is
all there is still the 19th of november
yeah all this is the 90s yeah yeah okay
yeah so you know i'm sure
well i mean here and here here and here
mike lee says unless powell can
immediately substantiate what she said
today the president should probably
disassociate himself which he then you
did that's right so they were listening
to mike lee here which this is kind of
crazy and the reason why it's kind of
crazy that they're listening to mike lee
is because there was something else
significant that i want to point out to
you that is absolutely batshit crazy and
this is the reason why um here's one um
about john eastman uh but i want to move
to another one but uh why we're here
john eastman has really interesting
research on this the good news is
is that eastman is proposing an approach
that unlike sydney powell has
proposed could be examined very quickly
in other words he's promoting the cheeto
dust kangaroo plan the john eastman is
still doing that [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah
well which uh he'll probably end up in
federal prison for yeah for several
years um let's see the one thing i
wanted to show though that i found in
these text messages which scared the
absolute [ __ ] bejesus out of me um i
was like holy actual [ __ ]
is that they were they were crowd
sourcing we know the president united
states donald trump at the time right
was listening to fox news right
but here is a united states senator let
me see if i can no text on on january 6
which is very interesting right right
right um but
that's 20 that's 20 20. right right
these are 20 20. the um
he was listening to mark levin and he's
telling mark meadows to go watch mark
levin's show on fox news because mark
levin lays it out on fox news
how we can overturn the cons
constitution of the united states it is
some weird ass [ __ ] to see a text
message from a sitting senator in the
united states who you think well they're
probably pretty smart right
texting the chief of staff who stands
november 23rd 2020 is that one if you
haven't watched tonight's episode of
life liberty 11 then that's it that's it
yeah that's it
yeah the 23rd yeah it was right there
above the eastman one yeah if you
haven't watched yet watched tonight's
episode of life liberty and levin that's
mark levin yeah [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
show on
on fox news you should do so if you can
fit it in levin makes a very compelling
case for the need to litigate re uh
litigation related to this election so
like literally they're saying out loud
go listen to fox news fox news has the
road map right they're broadcasting
yeah like this is absolute batshit
bonkers crazy folks
when you are in government and you are
serious about policy and you are serious
about what you're doing in government
you don't go watch a youtube video that
has q and on conspiracy theories right
you do not go watch a cable news station
like joe biden to figure out what
litigation he needs to have doesn't go
watch rachel maddow's show i would
seriously [ __ ] doubt if joe biden
even watches rachel maddow yeah i would
seriously doubt that he watches jake
tapper if
you
if you are in a political position
you're the president of the united
states let's say or you're just uh you
know
you're uh a u.s representative or
senator um
and you are saying hey you should go
listen to cause it's not oh let's just
call it's not fox news you know it's
faux news it's [ __ ] news it's
not really news it's entertainment it's
[ __ ] news
uh but in in that situation
if you are relying
on the opinion
of a person on a show who may have had
someone do some research and maybe
there's to some extent some truth to a
path forward doesn't mean that it's
actually a path it just means like oh
there might be a case to actually
present forward but it won't really hold
any ground
you know the fact that you would say oh
the president should ignore
uh his legal team or or the people
working for him and you know what they
didn't even think of this thing let's go
over to mark levin and listen to this
guy's show because he's got the answer
well if anyone doesn't know who mark
levin is because it's important to uh
point this out he is a right-wing talk
radio show host
that's what he is he is like a rush
limbaugh
and he was given a fox news show because
he's a [ __ ] fascist
and this guy was vehemently anti-trump
when trump wasn't the nominee in 2016. i
listened to mark levin a lot i used to
listen to wrestling ball sean hannity i
vehemently disagree with him and i
diametrically opposed almost everything
they believe but i listened to him
because i wanted to know what they were
saying because that's where these people
were hearing it and mark levin was
anti-trump because trump is a buffoon
and [ __ ] mark levin hated that about
trump that he's a [ __ ] buffoon now
he's a trump sycophant right because the
the tail is wagging the dog in this
country on the right wing yeah that's
what is happening the fascists have
taken over the party and they've taken
it over
um did you want to say something about
chip roy because they're the chip roy
also
right so chip chip roy is also one of uh
one of these people that threw
themselves in the text uh and
you know texting
mark meadows to again figure out you
know he's got stuff that's like we have
no tools data information to go out and
fight for the election fraud if you know
if you need wanna we all need to know
what's going on for what it's worth so
he's like
not part of the conversation uh again
has no
has no position to be in to to involve
himself
but is now trying to be like oh how do i
kiss this ass right how do i how do i
[ __ ] uh uh get get trump's attention
so that he knows that i am a loyal loyal
servant to him you know
and
uh
you know then there's like oh mark
meadows and chip roy thanks so much
working on it for the surrogates
briefing congratulations by the way it
goes yes sir now let's hold uh georgia
and take arizona and pennsylvania like
they're all talking about this stuff you
know behind the scenes
and
well they're even talking about how
they're on the phone with state
legislators day in and day out to try to
overturn this election exactly like
chip roy comes in no more than a kiss
ass he's just brown nosing at this point
in my opinion he put himself in the
situation or in the discussion with mark
meadows so that when you know push comes
to shove at the end of the day if trump
does come through he looks at all the
loyalists that were with him during that
time and says you stay you stay you stay
you stay and by that i mean like
my word trump's word which is means [ __ ]
in terms of like what he promises
i think that is that is trump's attempt
to say like oh those who are loyal to me
will have my undying support and uh and
admiration right uh which we've seen go
to the wayside with people like uh mo
brooks right who was very much for
january 6 pushing and fighting uh and
and disagreeing with the certification
and then now that he recently was like i
actually told trump not to do this i
think he i think he got interviewed by
federal prosecutors right and they're
like listen this is what you're actually
looking at and before i think a lot of
these people also are are under the
the guys or the the kind of uh idea that
they're not
going to be in any way held liable for
what was said or done
and the federal prosecutors come in
they're like listen so we got uh
communication on this this this this you
were here on these dates you said these
things we can connect you to these
people whether you were directly
involved you were indirectly involved
because of some sort of
something you did and they're like so
these are the charges realistic that we
can bring against you and then
uh he's like uh
okay okay okay um so what i really meant
to say was uh you know and then goes in
and then you know speaks out now these
people have to be publicly against trump
and anything he was trying to do for
january 6th and now trump says oh those
[ __ ] rat [ __ ] and then comes after
them to say that oh i don't trust them i
endorse the opposing candidate if
they're in a re-election campaign uh
it's like you know again
just like comey said like he's always
asking for loyalty and if you're not
proving to be loyal to him then he will
cut you
as soon as he can right and what yeah
and i'll tell you that
speaking of uh sycophants trying to
placate the trump uh our bonehead of the
week is one of those um the winner of
our bonehead of the week is governor
greg abbott and boy is he really is he
really uh sucking at the teeth of the
trump supporters here he goes to events
and says uh god hail trump and they're
like booing him and [ __ ] but um i got a
video here that i want to show that was
posted by his opponent um well maybe his
opponent
in the uh texas race for governor beto
o'rourke and this is a a lineup of
trucks
let me mute it here this is the line of
trucks that's waiting um to be inspected
by the highway patrol they're going to
check the tire pressure on these trucks
because they can't check the cargo as
everyone knows governor greg abbott is
really trying to make sure that your
grocery store shelves are empty he's old
empty shelves abbott uh and the reason
why is because he wants to try to step
up the supply chain on purpose so that
way it gets blamed on joe biden so when
you go vote you'll blame joe biden
you'll blame beto o'rourke and you'll
vote for him so he's using his power as
governor to get the texas what is
essentially the higher patrol in texas
to stop up the supply chain at our
border where we get a lot of food right
a lot of electronics a lot of vehicles
that is manufactured grown and brought
here from mexico um and which our
country relies on for those shelves that
you complain about being empty yeah you
know like tiffany's that you know
there's no right it's almost you know i
look at this and i'm like wow this is a
pretty effective truck convoy
right almost feel like greg abbott
should have been the one behind planning
the truck run boys actually stop them
that is true that is true because you
look at this and it's like you've got
wow
tons of freight containers in and
trailers on these trucks spoiling right
well you know the other thing too is
these truckers aren't interested in
being in a convoy they want to move
their wheels right and they want to go
to their destination now i also don't
know the situation here in terms of like
if anyone out there knows anything about
like
being a trucker or the trucking industry
what happens in this scenario you you
literally cannot move you're just
sitting the truck so are these people
getting paid plus overtime
from the trucking companies because that
like they're stacked they're technically
like they they cannot prevent it they're
they're late and and
overdue on delivery because
of a uh you know federal bureaucracy and
and uh abbott trying to
do something that's completely idiotic
but when i look at that i say like oh
well these truckers they can't they have
no control they cannot go through
they're being stopped
so are they getting paid are they not
getting paid you know uh like maybe
they're getting paid like the wheels if
the wheels aren't moving they're not
getting paid most truckers in this
country get paid per mile right so so
that's why that's why when you see a
truck why are the why is this like this
[ __ ] like if there was ever a truck or
convoy to like go against anything why
wouldn't it be this right like i look at
the situation i say this is this is
complete [ __ ] where a governor is
using his power to
to play around with uh withholding
supply chain going into the country
and the truckers are just like well i
guess i'll just sit in my truck like
what are they doing right like i don't
know why there's not some sort of like
uh protest to this well you know i'll
tell you that a lot of the trucking
industry in this country
unbeknownst to a lot of people
most of the truck drivers a very high
percentage of the truck drivers in this
country uh rather people like it or know
it or not a lot a lot of them are rural
people right but a big high percentage
of truck drivers in this country are are
immigrants they're immigrants um and the
reason why is because it is a you do you
have to have a high skill in truck
driving but it does not require a lot of
money a lot of resources to drive for a
big trucking company and you can
generally make a very good income in
this country uh driving a truck because
you get to drive so many miles now
there's different regulations like
between this point and that point and
this but you generally get a very good
income for your household by driving a
truck which you have to have a high
skill
but you don't have to have a lot of
money in education and and background
and experience you just have to have the
skill of driving so uh margie said here
uh she's like hey tony he changed it so
now he is having the mexican government
do it so he can't be blamed
right well i mean i mean he's still
doing it so i mean we're still going to
blame him yeah yeah we're still going to
blame it i mean obviously like it will
come down to semantics because like well
i'm not doing it right they're actually
inspect right now it's at the request of
greg abbott so now he's using
uh
mexico's taxpayer money right here's
what i'll tell you marge here's what
i'll tell you margie if if if there's
not a better sign that greg abbott knows
he's going to be blamed for this and
he's not and he's not getting the blame
pushed on the right person it's because
better o'rourke is actually doing his
job and running the campaign against him
but here's the thing is him pushing it
to the mexican government only tells me
that he knows it's very [ __ ]
unpopular and it's not a popular thing
to do and he will get blamed for it and
he doesn't want to be blamed for it
which is why we should blame him for it
and keep pressing him um so let's do
this let's give greg abbott his due of
the week we are over time but let's give
greg abbott's due the week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] greg abbott yeah [ __ ] him [ __ ]
because i also want to point out one
other thing that really pisses me off um
the guy straight up kidnapped and
trafficked people and sent them to dc
right many of them are saying one some
of them aren't even illegal right
they're not like that's one thing that's
uh that i was thinking about the other
day where i was like oh you know god
forbid somebody is just assumed to be
illegal or not a resident of the us
because of how they look right
i would have a draft in my tweets that i
did not even send out but i was like oh
i guarantee that there's probably going
to be some people that come forward or
reveal that greg abbott just goes you
look brown you look mexican
you're on you're out right you're out
but the other thing is there were
reports of people saying that they were
going to florida
right they're going to be deported to
florida outside of texas but really what
ends up happening is they get pumped up
and shipped out to to new york or to dc
and uh uh
they were just openly admitting like oh
yeah we took people against their will
we put them to a place that uh that they
didn't agree to or they weren't aware of
we trafficked people you know across
state lines we kidnapped them against
their
uh against their their will you know and
then obviously people on the right are
gonna be like oh well they're illegal or
they're not residents they don't have
god they don't have god given right yeah
yeah they don't have god-given rights
it's this is all ridiculous and they're
there and i talked about this earlier in
the show on the statistic that there's
five million more jobs than we have
unemployed people in this country and
the reason why and rachel pointed out
very clearly that we
we so have demonized migrants and
immigrants in this country
migrants and immigrants in this country
play such a vital role into getting food
on our [ __ ] tables that people do not
understand it and it is very important
that we fill a lot of those positions so
when you go to your restaurant when you
go and you see shortages where they're
they're having to close down early or
they can't
guys it's because because the republican
party is demonizing immigration they're
demonizing immigrants they're demonizing
migrants to come to our country and to
work here they are part of our workforce
whether you [ __ ] like it or not they
are part of our workforce they're vital
to our country whether they're legal or
illegal whatever the hell you want to
say they are vital to our economy and
they're vital to our country so great
point on that um [ __ ] greg abbott [ __ ]
him
because as the as the as the the son of
an immigrant to this country i'm
mexican-american
and
this [ __ ]
is
is is disgusting and the fact that it
was kind of like well whatever you know
you know they pushed him up there and
was some political move in terms of for
greg abbott to like make a point that
it's joe biden's border problem
well you know the fact that brit is okay
and there's seems to be no repercussions
for the fact that greg abbott is just
trafficking people or or kidnapping them
against their will and what they were
told they were going to go
where they were going to go versus where
they actually went is insane
and of course the group on the right you
know gqp right-wing extremists whatever
you want to call them look at that and
they go yeah well
they had it coming like what the [ __ ] is
that [ __ ] well so they're they're
they're brown so who cares right right i
mean that's that's that's really what it
is right and it's racism is what it is
let's just call it the way it is so [ __ ]
greg abbott [ __ ] him and i'm glad he's
the bone of the week thank you remember
go to tony michael's pod to vote every
single week and bone of the week and
then every friday in the second hour of
the tony michaels broadcast me and gabe
break down your vote your vote for
bonehead of the week thanks for joining
us stick around we'll be right back
after the song
[Music]
[Applause]
all right whoa
great transition thanks for joining us
thanks for joining us for the entire
week right here on the tony michaels
podcast monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central 9 pacific youtube
twitter twitch don't forget to go over
to youtube and follow and subscribe to
our youtube channel just type in the
tony michael's podcast you will find it
and now we are broadcasting live from
the minus touch facebook page look out
this weekend we'll go ahead and put
bonehead of the week up on the um on the
youtube page uh
we've been thinking about doing some
different things and posting more clips
on the youtube so definitely definitely
go over and subscribe to the youtube
page you're not going to want to miss
some of these clips some of these things
that we put up on youtube
you're not going to want to miss it and
until next monday have a great easter
have a great weekend yeah but we will be
here monday noon eastern
youtube twitter twitch and the midas
touch facebook page until then have a
great weekend great easter
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking